[موسيقى]
في يوم غد الخميس سيتساوى فيه طول الليل
مع النهار على جميع انحاء المعموره وش
يعني هذا يعني ان الشمس تشرق وتغرب بنفس
موعدها وتشرق الشمس من المشرق تماما وتغرب
من المغرب تماما وتساوي الليل والنهار لا
يكون الا في يومين في السنه يوم الاعتدال
الربيعي 16 مارس ويوم الاعتدال الخريف في
27 سبتمبر رب المشرقين ورب المغربين فباي
الاء ربكما تكذبان وتساوي الليل والنهار
معناه الليل 12 ساعه والنهار 12 ساعه هذا
عندنا اما على القطب الشمالي فستشرق الشمس
ولن تغرب الا بعد سته شهور وعلى القطب
الجنوبي ستغرب الشمس ولن تشرق الا بعد سته
شهور فالليل سته اشهر والنهار سته اشهر
والليل تقلبوا مع النهار طوال ايام السنه
ما عدا المناطق الواقعه على خط الاستواء
ليش لكرويه الارض ودورانها حول نفسها
ودورانها حول الشمس وميلان محور دورانها
وهذا الدوران هو العمر تمر بين الايام
وتترى وانما نساق الى الاجال والعين تنظر
فلا عائد هذا الشباب الذي مضى ولا زائل
هذا المشيب المكدر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]